I totally had a crush on Han Solo but
Ponce's gonna take now I just want to
watch Star Wars in this pillow fort
right now we've never made a blanket for
it together and oh we have a big good
point yeah who's gonna be the best
blanket fort ever my forte was umbrella
for its ah she's actually gonna be the
one building the fort and we're just
gonna watch ready set go
no maybe if we just like flanked either
side yes we need a bunny does what I'm
gonna do Quinta well first things first
we need to make the floor pushy
Oh Oh how's it going smells it's good
it's good how do you say it in Chinese a
shine Asia bouncing team oh I know
look anyone can join in iron coins being
an adult sucks sometimes she's just
chilling you're not even helping us okay
dog action no one will ever be able to
find guys no just before it died no yes
Starlin darling welcome to Starling
goodbye why don't we do this more often
yeah we should
dude you got like fifty billion trillion
marshmallows in there oh did you know
it's my birthday today I just need a
really big book now if we lay back we
can look at this chart oh we also need
like a no boys allowed sign what kind of
noise is an octopus make I want it to be
exactly what I am right now when I was
growing up I wanted to become a NASCAR
driver
that explains the way you drive I think
this makes me think maybe I take my life
a little too seriously
same